we're in a rural part of northern Iraq
here halfway between the cities of Erbil
and Mosul and this is the location where
one of the various missiles that were
fired from Iran into Iraq overnight
where it came down it missed its
intended target by quite a wide margin
it was supposed to come down at the
airbase which is next to Erbil
International Airport which is about 50
kilometers away from here to the east of
here instead it's hit this this field
there were no injuries here we've been
talking to a few of the locals who have
told us and just how loud the explosions
were and around about 2 o'clock local
time this morning so this particular
missile missed its target as I say from
what we understand one missile at did
here to the air base at Erbil but there
are no reports of any coalition injuries
at least attack down at the Al Asad
airbase was much much more sustained I
think what this demonstrates although
these missiles missed their intended
targets what it demonstrates is that
Iran can and will from its own soil
attack American targets inside Iraq